what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data if
this is your first time here my name is
richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming so subscribe
for all kinds of content just like this
if you haven't already and at the
notification bowel so youtube notifies
you whenever I upload a video so we're
gonna do something completely different
today from anything I've done with this
YouTube channel so far notice I've got
an R script in the background here
specifically it's the it's the script of
a R markdown document and we're gonna
talk about t-tests and violations to the
assumptions of t-tests today so if
you've seen any of my statistics
tutorial videos you've probably noticed
that I rail on the assumptions of
t-tests and how violations that these
things are usually not the worst things
in the world so in any intro stats class
you're going to learn about what the
assumptions are t-tests are but what I
think far too often doesn't get brought
up is how robust the t-test is to
violations of these assumptions and so
it's really easy to imagine somebody
will come out of school and then there
will be a situation where a t-test is
appropriate or I mean the same principle
here can apply to any kind of
statistical method that carries with it
assumptions you're gonna test for things
like normality or variance and as is the
case with most real-world data these
things are going to be violated and I
don't want people to get scared by that
because a lot of the times that t-test
is gonna be super valuable regardless so
I don't want to tell any of you guys
what to think
but what we're gonna do here today is
we're gonna look at some scenarios in
which in which assumptions of the t-test
are violated and then we're gonna look
at how big of an impact that actually
makes and so I can't simulate every
possible violation of these things that
can occur
like every situation is going to be a
little bit different but I just want to
instill some useful food for thought and
you guys and maybe get you thinking
about some things you can check next
time you have assumptions that are
violated because it may be that the
method you're using is way more robust
and it's gonna work just fine and the
method you're using is just way more
robust than you actually think it is so
this is gonna be a lot of fun here
before we get started here just a few
asks from you guys number one please
take one second of your time and smash
the like button that really helps my
content get suggested more and reach a
larger audience also I have made it a
sworn goal at least at this time any way
that I am never gonna run any kind of
paid course because I think there's way
way way too many of those things out
there on the Internet's not all of them
which are super valuable and quite
frankly I always want the content that I
produce to be freely available to people
but I do have a link to my patreon
account in the description so if you're
willing to pitch in two dollars a month
three dollars a month anything like that
in order to help support my work that is
that would be massively appreciated and
will really help me to continue doing
things like this and then also this code
is going to be available on github so I
will also have a link in the description
of this video to the github account that
I have set up for this YouTube channel
so you'll be able to go through the code
here and just convince yourself of these
things and you know really really step
through this stuff in in detail so
without further ado let's get started so
I'm going to initialize a few things
here right off the bat and I'll explain
the motivation for for this stuff in
just a moment here but first and
foremost just a refresher on what the
assumptions of a two-sample t-tests are
and a two-sample kind is the one that
we're going to focus on in this video
but the first assumption is that we have
samples taken from normally distributed
populations now this is something that a
lot of people just kind of gloss over
and it's just because at the end of the
day all that it really comes down to is
x-bar being normally distributed but if
you have a large enough sample size
x-bar is going to be approximately
normally distributed anyway I mean that
is what the central limit theorem tells
us anyway and the conventional wisdom
tells us that the sample size needs to
be approximately 25 to 30 or greater and
actually we're gonna see with this one
this one isn't even totally the case all
the time you also assume that the
populations have equal variance and also
that you have independence within
populations as well as between the
different populations so we're gonna use
simulation here to see if these things
are truly meaningful and we're gonna
look at seven different scenarios we're
gonna look at the scenario in which none
of these assumptions are violated we're
gonna look at a situation in which we're
taking samples of size ten from two
populations which are uniformly
distributed samples of size ten from two
populations which are exponentially
distributed then we're gonna do samples
of size 50 from two populations which
differ massively in are not massively I
should say but populations with
different standard deviations the
standard deviations are off by to
remember that our parameter eise's these
things this way first number is the mean
second number is the standard deviation
meaning the standard deviations are off
by two so the variance will be off by
four or factor four that is next
scenario we had the standard deviations
off by a factor of five which means the
variance is going to be off by a factor
of 25 we're gonna see how big of a
difference that actually makes and then
we're gonna look at what happens when we
have dependence within the populations
as well as between population
next now the thing we're gonna focus on
here is gonna be the significance level
so we're going to set it to where
theoretically it should be equal to 0.05
and we're going to see if in all these
scenarios in the simulations if the
observed significance level is actually
going to be equal to point zero five now
remember with the significance level
that's just the probability of making a
type one error that is the probability
we reject the null hypothesis when the
null hypothesis is true
and the null hypothesis is going to be
true in all these instances here in
every scenario here the means are equal
to each other now if you guys want to do
go through a similar exercise where the
means are different from each other and
you do something similar with power
you're more than welcome to do so now
admittedly this code is not the fastest
in the world so I'm gonna start a few
things here and get our first example
going here and explain what's going on
while it runs so first and foremost we
have a a function defined here for
calculating a T statistic now this is
all quite straightforward stuff one
thing to point out here is that there
are different ways of calculating the T
statistic if you do in fact assume that
the that the variances are equal to one
another so if you do then you calculate
a pooled standard error so that's what
we're that's what we're gonna do here
and then that T statistic function is
going to get run inside this Monte Carlo
T function here so let me just explain
all the moving parts to this first of
all let's initialize two vectors we're
gonna call them values and prob now
what's happening inside here is we're
going to store a whole bunch of
different T statistic values inside this
vector called values it's going to have
to have size equal to this this variable
I've defined and rep
that's equal to 5,000 so I've got it set
up to where it's evaluating oops let's
scroll back up here just so you see
what's going on
it's evaluating text strings here so in
our instance here it evaluated normal
sampling from a normal random variable
size 10 with mean equal to 100 and
standard deviation equal to 10 pooling
our variances so we're going to store
5,000 different T statistics we're then
going to find out how many were had an
absolute value above the critical value
for such a t-test divided by the overall
length that is the number of T
statistics that we have so just as a
reminder again if our T statistic is
above this critical threshold we reject
the null hypothesis we figure out the
rate that is the number of times that
this is actually occurring and then
we're going to repeat that entire
process 100 times because we want to
have some idea of our sampling error
here so that's basically what we're
doing here I'll explain this one because
we're only gonna use this one one time
so I'll come back later and explain that
one just from the next chunk of code
here and yeah so what we found here was
our estimate of the type 1 error rate
was five point zero three five percent
and again this is under the situation in
which there are no assumptions violated
so I mean five point zero three percent
and the standard error is really really
really small here five point zero three
percent is really really close to five
percent again nothing's off here that's
all about what we'd expect from a pure
sampling error kind of situation so in
our next situation this is a scenario in
which we are actually violating one of
the assumptions of a t-test and right
now and we're going to have samples from
uniform 0 to 100 populations
and the samples are a size 10 so we
don't have normality here and also based
on the conventional wisdom out here
which would tell you you need a sample
size of 25 there are 230 or greater in
both groups they say you need that for
the central limit theorem to be
effective we don't have that here either
the next chunk here uh and this code
just finished so we so the jury's out on
this one so we get an estimate of type
one error to be 5.1 seven percent and
the standard error here of that estimate
is I mean similarly small it's insanely
small and so type 1 error when we
violated this assumption went from like
five point zero three five percent tough
five point one seven four two percent so
there's not really a hard fast rule for
looking at that and saying well that's
that's a really egregious violation or
it's not but personally I look at that
and considering just how small of a
difference that is I mean this is so
small that I really don't think that
this is any kind of serious violation
that you really need to be concerned
about five point one seven percent is
pretty close to five point zero zero
percent or five point zero three percent
in the case of the scenario that we ran
before so not a big difference the next
thing that we do here is we run from a
we run samples from two exponential
populations now notice this one was a
little bit more off
we actually got a type one error rate of
four point three eight percent and again
in this situation we don't have
normality we have exponential
distributions and we have samples of
size ten so apparently the central limit
theorem didn't quite work out for us
that well in this particular scenario
now to be fair with the exponential
distribution
is a very skewed right distribution so
you're gonna have a lot more outliers
and again your sample mean the sample
mean x-bar is pretty sensitive to
outliers and especially in situations
with size 10 you're going to see things
like that having a pretty significant
impact hence you're going to have weird
things show up when you when this
particular assumption is violated for a
t-test the uniform distribution by
contrast the uniform distribution is a
symmetric distribution much like the way
much much like a normal distribution so
that scenario was robust to our
assumptions four point three seven six
percent when it should be five percent
again you may look at that and say
that's not the worst thing in the world
and and yeah it's probably not but it
certainly were certainly off by more in
this situation than we were with the
with the uniform distribution and
violating the assumptions that way so in
our next scenario here we were sampling
from populations that were normally
distributed with a mean equal to 100
standard deviation equal to 10 and
normally distributed population with
mean equal to 100 and standard deviation
equal to 20 and so we're not gonna pull
the standard deviations here uh but yeah
just notice here we ended up with an
estimate of our type 1 error right here
and this is really not off at all I mean
five point zero seven percent this is
pretty close to the five point zero 3
percent situation we had when we weren't
violating anything now granted I
purposely set this one up to where we
have a higher sample size so I mean take
take that for what it's worth to but
this violation really done of this
violation of the assumption of variances
being equal really did not cause us any
kind of serious problems that we need to
be worried about
in our next situation here which is
still running
we have variances off by a significantly
larger amount again standard deviations
are off by a factor five that means the
variance is going to be off by a factor
of twenty-five and lo and behold the
type 1 error estimate here is five point
two one percent so again that's really
really not that bad that's really not
something that I would particularly be
worried about on considering in real
life scenarios I mean think about it are
you gonna have two samples in which your
standard deviations are off by five like
that's a lot to be off by and it's still
not causing that much of a problem so so
yay we are violating the assumptions and
we're still getting results which could
even be meaningful so all this is
incredibly promising stuff so now we're
gonna look at the situation in which we
have a correlation within our population
now I'm not gonna go through all the
nitty-gritty of this code because I
would be here for too long explaining
all this but basically it's based on a
cholesky decomposition and we're going
to get it to where within our samples we
have correlated data now this shows up
in a variety of practical scenarios
particularly a lot of things in the
healthcare or pharmaceutical space where
you're taking repeated measurements on
individuals so for instance if you
measure somebody's let's just say it's
blood pressure you take that measurement
and then you take another measurement on
that individual well you already have a
little bit more information on what that
second observation is based on that
first observation you always have this
kind of dependent structure when you
have repeated measurements let's say by
individual and there are tons of
examples that are similar to this and
where you could have dependent data
within samples and we're going to see
the difference that makes I created a
new function for this called T stat core
and it's going to be based on
taking correlation matrices and oops um
where were we
yep right here you have correlation mate
matrices and you're taking the dot
product of that matrix with the with the
distributions of interest here so what
we end up getting here is a type 1 error
rate estimate of point zero zero zero
two four six so we found out that
violating this assumption was a really
really serious serious egregious problem
I mean this is bad I mean this is I mean
when I created this example just
hypothetically like to have a
correlation of 0.7 within populations
I mean you guys have all this code you
can verify all these things for yourself
and you play around with that personally
I was expecting it to be off by a little
bit I was not expecting it to be off by
this much and again this is from this is
start from starting points of a sample
sizes of ten where your mean would be
100 and standard deviation is equal to
10 and then you're multiplying these
things by correlation matrices but still
there's nothing going on here that would
create a bias to where you would have
one like either X or Y that's supposed
to be systematically higher than the
other so yeah this one is really really
bizarre so yeah this one is a serious of
violation of us of an assumption and in
our last example here we're gonna look
at a scenario where we have a
correlation of 0.7 between our samples
that is our populations are dependent of
one another and the way we're going to
set this up is I'm gonna create a
multivariate normal distribution here so
what you're gonna do here is and I mean
you can create something similar and you
can play around with the parameters to
this if you want to be just convinced
that all this works
but we're going to create a mu vector
equal to one hundred and one hundred you
create a covariance matrix Sigma so that
when we take column one and column two
we're going to have samples from that
population which we're creating up front
here to where the mean is going to be
equal to one hundred the standard
deviation is equal to ten and the
populations aren't dependent of one
another uh so yeah let's take a yeah
let's take a look and see here how this
how this is gonna work out for us again
we saw up above here this right here was
a horribly serious violation so I mean I
this one's working here you're probably
taking a guess in your head about what
this is gonna look like I'm excited I
hope you guys are watching along to this
and you're as excited to see this as I
am
oh wow this is a slow one there we go
all right so we end up with an estimate
of type 1 error rate equal to four point
nine nine four percent and the standard
error looks pretty similar to that so
again even with the correlation between
our samples so our populations are
dependent of one another
again I mean check this code you can go
through it and convince yourself that
this works if you want if that guys
highly encourage those of you watching
along to do that but notice here we
still have a type 1 error rate that's
really close to point zero 5 so if
you're to take anything away from this
the dependence width in samples that is
a really serious problem that's gonna
cause you to either systematically
overestimate or underestimate the true
variability of your data and when that
happens you're gonna get significance
levels which are highly off from what
they should be theoretically but you
violate a lot of these other assumptions
I mean this didn't even turn out to be a
big deal when we're when we're
simulating from you know populations
which are correlated to one another and
this thing up top here with the samples
from exponential populations you know
that causes the type 1 error rate to be
off by a little bit but it's not that
bad
so I mean make of this what you will
again there are situations in which you
can violate these assumptions and then
you're gonna have results that are off
by quite a lot it all comes down to just
how badly you're violating these
assumptions but for a lot of them I
think it's fair to take away here that
violating these assumptions is not going
to be the worst thing in the world the
t-test is a really robust test and it's
pretty good now in apply data science
work that's not to say you're gonna
spend all of your day just running T
tests one after another after another
um but having said that it's a pretty
good tool when the situation calls for
it so so make of all this what you will
I will leave it there so thanks all of
you for watching this video if you
enjoyed it
once again please hit the like button
also let me a call leave me a comment
down below and let me know what you guys
think then I'll see you all in the not
so distant future until then Richard
non-data